We have five
different games
and $500
Whenever somebody beats us
they win $100
and we move on
to the next challenge!
First up
The random bounce racket!
I’ll set the score to beat
and if you can beat it
you get $100!
Sick!
Okay, five!
You have to get six!
and only one try!
Fair play!
That’s awesome gents!
Alright let’s try it!
Okay ready?
Nooooo!
Thanks guys have a good day!
Hey guys
if you can bounce the ball
more times than me
you win $100
What happens if not?
Nothing!
That was so close!
Good try!
You wanna try it?
Yeah
Only two!!
That’s possible!
So if you get three
you win a hundred dollars
Perfect, alright, sounds good!
No pressure!
Oh my god!
That’s unlucky...
Good try, good try...
We’re gonna continue until
someone can beat me!
Next challenge is mini ping pong!
One rally
If you win that rally
you win one hundred dollars
Oh my god!
Are you really good at ping pong?
Well, we’ll see!
Good try, good try!
Bye bye!
Walking down the main street
Should we just do here?
The tempo is high!
That was intense!
Sensei! You’re a Sensei!
One point only!
Too small man!
It’s very small
Oh it’s...Yeah
You must be real good
You too!
Bye bye!
Thank you have a good day!
That was a close one!
We have a little challenge for you!
If you win one point
you get $100
$100?
Yeah, one point!
You get to serve
Here is $100!
Thank you have a good day!
Congrats!
I’ll buy breakfast with this!
You have amazing serves!
Yeah that’s all
Let’s move to the next challenge!
Time for beerpong!
Let’s go!
Okay, so you know the rules?
You go ahead
First try?!
We should definitely not
do this challenge in the US
I’ll subscribe right now!
And guys
if you haven’t subscribed to
Pongfinity yet
now is a good time to do that!
If somebody gets more bounces
than us
they win $100
Two
Three
Four
So we’ll see
It’s not that easy!
C’est windy eh?
Three!
That’s cheating!
Good try!
Thanks for the try!
We would have a little
challenge for you!
That’s a new record!
It’s coming home innit!
You guys win!!
That’s $100!
for winning the challenge!
Nice congrats guys!
I’ll check your channel out!
What’s it called?
Pongfinity!
Remember to subscribe!
SUBSCRIBE!
Hit the ping pong cup
off of Emil’s head!
First one to knock it off
wins!
I feel bad
I feel like I might hit him
Don’t worry, don’t worry!
That was close!
So as I said
don’t worry about hitting him!
I lost, alright guys!
So you survived the first round
I did, I did
However you want
Nice try!
Almost had it!
First try
on that one
If you can knock the cup off his head
you win $100
Not like that
With a ping pong ball!
Yeah there we have it!
Don’t worry about hitting him
He’s used to it
Sorry!
No problem!
I’m terrified after that one
I think I also have to go hard
I’m just gonna place the cup here
You go for it!
Close!
You have a good technique there
Sorry I had to go for it
I didn’t see that coming at all!
I need to come and try!
You gotta try!
So sorry!
Don’t worry about it!
Bit high
That was close!
Keep going man!
Alright here we go!
How many turns do I get?
You just have to beat him
So, do it before...
You got it!
Winner!
Winner winner, chicken dinner!
Here you go honey
That’s for your Starbuck’s
Oh that’s very nice
Give it to my daughter
Thank you guys
You guys are awesome!
You can win $100
If you can get more bounces
than me with this racket
Okay
Yo, shoutout everyone bro
Shoutout my G for real
Thank you, good try!
This is haard!
More bounces?
All you gotta do is to beat me
Four bounces
I can get it!
Here we have our friends again
If you get more bounces than me
you win $100
Wow
Did you lose?
We got two...
Only two!
Three bounces, if you can do it
you win $100
You’d be the first one today
to beat me
There we have it!
Yes!
You got it!
We found a winner!
Wooow
Congratulations!
We’ll follow your channel!
It’s called Pongfinity!